clayton kershaw joining us on program
the Dodger left-hander where are you
right now
sorry I was a little late I kind of
forgot about you Dan my fault Wow Wow
have you ever been late for a start as
far as getting to the ballpark no I've
had some actually opening day in LA when
it's in the middle of the week you know
you kind of traffic gets a little bad so
I have had I've had that skipped some
turns and cut some corners to make it on
time and been pulled over a couple of
times actually for doing that wait you
got pulled did you get a ticket yeah so
when you go to Dodger Stadium there's
like a little route that you can go
that's just for the neighborhoods and
I've had to use that a couple times and
there's always a policeman right there
waiting to get guys and thankfully
they've let me go every time but I have
had to stop and explain what's going on
so well it's weird you have your uniform
on when you're driving so of course it
probably helps you right it's like
Little League you know you loved it so
much you couldn't wait for him do you
have a nightmare when it comes to
pitching like I have a nightmare that
I'm always gonna be late for
SportsCenter when I did SportsCenter
that I've somehow I'm gonna get there
and I'm not prepared do you have
anything pitching wise no I don't have a
nightmare like you don't think about I
can't get anybody out I always like the
reality no and so you get out there you
never really know if you're gonna be
able to do it so you kind of always
figured out after that first pitch but I
think that's just like pregame you know
nerves you know what have you been told
about the season nothing I haven't been
told anything yet you know obviously the
I think California just did the no fan
thing so honestly I'm kind of waiting
for today's meeting to figure out what
we're doing I think you can't have a
gathering of more than 250 people yeah
so whether that means like empty
stadiums or we stay here or what but I
haven't heard anything yet to be honest
but even where you're socializing with
fans
have you been told about you know how
much interaction you can have with fans
during spring training or its
socializing with other player Lincoln's
it's sort of strange now with what
happened with the Utah Jazz yeah it is
weird I mean I think you know those are
the things so nobody access in the
clubhouse is trying to alleviate some of
that and then you say like try to
restrict autographs and try to like you
know maybe not give your teammates high
fives but that's just I mean that's
that's really hard to do you know so
just wash your hands more I guess
there's the only thing I'm really doing
yeah but you guys are disgusting though
you're always like licking your fingers
and Rowan appalled and spitting and I
mean come on your gut you guys are like
a petri dish yeah I mean I would agree
when you put it like that but I won't
say basketball basketball and hockey are
a little bit different in that like
they're literally sweating all over each
other you know checking guys and posting
up and things like that so that seems
more like a hotbed than like a baseball
game in my opinion but I'm no no doctor
are you allowed to like how much sweat
are you allowed to use on a baseball how
much sweat yeah like I wanted helping
foreign substances but I think I'll just
make it flicker wouldn't it I think
that'd make it worse yeah but if you
throw a spit ball like not that you
threw a spit ball but I I'm just
wondering if like where are you allowed
to put on a baseball now where yeah you
don't and are you okay if everybody uses
pine tar to be able to grip the ball
better has become a little bit of a
hot-button topic yeah yeah I think as
long as you try to get a grip on the
baseball I'm not really worried about
what guys are using I think if we can
make a uniform and everybody use the
same thing and like you know how you
have the rosin bag out on the pitcher's
mound if you put X substance behind the
pitcher's mound and was a found a way to
kind of regulate that then I think that
would be great but the balls or the
balls are really really slick coming out
of the thing so yeah you can use sweat
and rosin and that kind of does the
trick but if they had one more thing
behind the mound to help us so I would
be great
just like hitters ooh they're bats I
mean they're putting all sorts of stuff
on their bat we're talking to click
Clayton Kershaw and the Dodgers pitcher
how did you greet Mookie Betts when you
first met him how did I greet him I was
excited I probably didn't match my level
of excitement but I was he wasn't as
excited to meet you I think I probably
caught him off guard but yeah he's been
great man he's gonna be awesome for us
and I honestly didn't know much about
him you know we don't play him a ton and
he's just he's just an awesome guy you
know you talk about like great presence
in the clubhouse and all that stuff he's
been awesome this name would be you know
David's been awesome too and I've always
loved watching him pitch so it's gonna
be awesome
we haven't spoken since the Astros
scandal what happened you know but I
wonder about this though Clayton you
know it you know in all sincerity you
know we look at your legacy and
everybody talks about a great
regular-season pitcher but and you go
back to that game against the Astros and
they weren't swinging and missing and
it's it's impossible to face you when
you're throwing your curveball or you're
throwing that changeup and nobody's
missing any pitches there did you feel
it in a moment that something was up
no you know I don't really you know in
the moment obviously it just it just
sucks you know you get deed and you know
you have to go back and do all those
things and you know you get back on a
plane and go back and think about it and
yeah it's no fun and you know I think
obviously it's it's no secret that we
were all affected by it you know as far
as would we World Series or whatever you
guys let myself think about it you know
what happened it's over you know I was
upset about it we've gone just try to do
the best you can with that and you know
I could get all hot and bothered by it
but it's not going to change anything
and you know as far as legacy and all
that stuff I'm not worried about that
you know I'm just not and whatever it is
at the end of my career will be good and
said I was longer than the teammates
as long as my teammate respect what I'm
doing and they want me out there then
you know I think I think that's a good
career so that's that's what I try to
focus on well I mean it's admirable to
do that well I I hope that's how you
feel I just you know when you're
watching it I now you think back on it I
mean they were teeing off on you and I
just I find it amazing and they were
teeing off on others and you just go
okay man they're hitting the ball solid
and nobody's missing any of your pitches
and that's where you know you start to
go Kylie that that's strange and like I
would be angry I feel like I was cheated
but at some point I understand I have to
move on
and you know I commend you if you're
able to move on I I don't know if I
could move on this quickly yeah I'm good
with it and I think I've talked so much
about it now that it's like I I don't
even have anything to say anymore it's
all good and I mean hopefully we have a
season this year and would you rather
talk about the coronavirus then the
Astros cheating scandal what do you want
to talk what question do you have for me
who is your last interview let me see I
had Jay Bilas on from ESPN yeah yeah
let's talk about what are they doing
March Madness wise so they're gonna
still do that you think or just do empty
crowds they are probably going to play
in front of empty arenas man that will
be weird and that'd be weird for
baseball - I can't imagine - I know the
Oriole White Sox did that when they had
the riots in Baltimore but I can't
imagine doing that that would be so
crazy but have you ever pitched in front
of a really really sparse crowd oh yeah
all the time
at least I was like there's still an
atmosphere of a major league game like
like even when you play a day game in
like a city that doesn't draw like
there's still at least like 10,000
people there you know like zero people
that would just be would be so difficult
well then you can hear everything there
were times when I would tune into a game
and I'd go I can
the guy down the third-base line who's
ordering something you know that that I
liked it it brought me closer to the
game I think we're gonna hear a lot of
things on the basketball court that
we've never heard before yeah I mean I
guess that's true
I just as a player like players
perspective like the adrenaline the rush
that you get from having a crowd and
like hearing the roar and things like
that like that's that's something that
you just learn how to pitch with and it
elevates a lot of people game and so I
think to try to create that atmosphere
and that adrenaline for a game with no
fans is going to be very difficult for a
lot of guys and when the Astros use the
garbage can it's going to be louder this
time around obviously right I think they
might get caught this time Hey great to
talk to you good luck in the upcoming
season you're in our bracket challenge
aren't you we have to have a tournament
but yeah if there's a tournament then
yeah you're in the bracket challenge all
right all right Thank You Clayton all
right that's Clayton Kershaw the Dodgers
pitcher